5. focala now getting Medical Care in
the middle of a war zone can be nearly
impossible for those injured in the
conflict between Russia and Ukraine
trauma treatment is coming all the way
from the United States tissue donated by
someone who has long since passed away
can offer The Gift of Life and sight
for more than 15 months
Ukraine has been under siege with
hundreds of thousands of lives lost on
both sides of the conflict it was raised
and I got my education and Soviet Union
for Dr Elena villalova watching her
country divided prompted her to take
action her company ilife International
facilitates Eye tissue distribution
worldwide and one day she got a call we
have truck from Germany going to Ukraine
with all you know humanitarian Aid and
the Nations and everything tapping into
her network she asked ibanks including
the Nevada donor Network to donate
tissue to help injured ukrainians
according itself Chris Johns is director
of ocular Services she was trying to
build a Consortium of ibanks that could
combine their inventory together and
send over for those that are injured due
to the dire circumstances only tissue
that had long-term preservation and
required no Refrigeration could be used
they can also be used in combat because
they are shelf stable they don't require
refrigeration for up to two years six
eye Banks across the country
participated donating eye tissue in
boxes much like these they were sent via
FedEx flight to a doctor in Germany but
then the tricky part the tissue was
moved to trucks driving through the war
zone reaching five facilities across
Ukraine yes it was it was crazy Jordan
yeah of course I was worried I worried
that maybe you know damaged during
Transportation
uh it could be so many thing happened it
took about two to three weeks for all of
the donations to arrive and nearly 100
people were treated but we'll never know
who they were or how they're doing it's
a great feeling when you get when you
help people helping people heal is what
the Nevada donor network is all about
and luckily in this country there is no
wait list for corneal tissue when we do
have Surplus gifts that we can share
with the rest of the world we're happy
to do so
so the tissue was used for Battlefield
injuries and so for many patients as a
way to actually preserve their eye until
they can get to a specialist which many
times was out of the country and it is
very likely Ukrainian doctors will need
to reach out once again to ask for this
type of help